what is sirs and what can trigger it
serves as a chronic inflammatory
response syndrome we have two sides to
our immune system one is the innate
immune side and the one is the Adaptive
and when the Invader it's a lot more
complicated the innate sidewall then
release antigens or Communications to
the Adaptive side of saying hey T cells
B cells memory cells I need you to come
in and remove this toxin because we
can't handle it so the way that it does
that is it releases all these immune
things to communicate and then normally
the Adaptive side will come in and
remove it that 20 to 25 of the
population cannot do the trade-off so
what ends up happening is we get exposed
to these biotoxins and it gets into our
system and the 20 of the population does
not recognize to remove it even though
the innate side sees it and so what ends
up happening is over time the
inflammatory response has gone awry and
that's the illness and so what we're
trying to do over time with sirs is
essentially we're trying to crawl that
immune response